à commencer à décrypter un ce qui est en
train de dire ce qui est en train d'être
d'être dit le président ukrainien le
président estonien qui s'expriment
côte-à-côte déjà symboliquement c'est
très fort c'est son allié qui est venu à
ses côtés pour lui témoigner nouveau de
son soutien en ces heures difficiles
oui c'est intéressant quand on écoute le
président estonien parce que on se rend
bien compte dans ces cas là qu'on est
avec un discours assez ferme d'un pays
baltes et les pays baltes ont vécu
l'empiré soviétique il faisait partie de
la cour de la deûle empire soviétique
ils sont partis comme la crème au moment
de la chute du mur et après en dans les
années 90 quand on a créé tous ces pays
et on sent très clairement de la part
des estoniens qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
convaincus que le sont par exemple des
français des italiens des espagnols qui
sont européens comme eux de l'appétit de
l'ogre russe et qu' il dise tout de
suite qu'il faut se défendre qu'il faut
dire que les frontières sont
indivisibles un discours beaucoup plus
marquée d'avoir effectivement on a
entendu ce matin le ministre ukrainien
de la défense avoir des mots très forts
le kremlin veut ressusciter
l'urss est évidemment ce qui est dans
toutes les têtes et notamment dans les
têtes de ces de ses pays voisins le
spectre d'une attaque russe de l'ukraine
ça ravive de douloureux souvenirs à
l'estonie mais pas que allah à la
lituanie à la lettonie à la lituanie
aussi hein ça ravive effectivement dans
les pays baltes ça ravive aussi en
pologne par exemple où finalement on se
souvient que l'open y est un pays très
moderne mais quand on y met les pieds
les gens ont tout de suite des souvenirs
d'enfance qui vous ramène dans l' empire
soviétique il savait exactement ce que
c'était que d'avoir par exemple des
pénuries de pain de viande que ce que
c'est que d'avoir des frontières qui
était infranchissable
nous français nous n'avons pas connu ça
de la même manière dont ça permet
effectivement d'avoir un peu le tempo de
cette région là et de comprendre aussi
pourquoi est-ce que souvent elle est
très pro atlantique et souvent elle veut
croire que les américains vont aider
elle dit qu'il faut absolument avoir des
relations avec les amériques a plutôt
avec l'otan d'ailleurs qu'avec une
europe de la défense parce que justement
les américains sont présentés comme
sauveur hélas ce qui est intéressant
quand on écoute le président céline ski
c'est qu'on voit quand même que lui
comme il est directement concerné c'est
son pays l'a pas envie d'avoir une
guerre et donc il laissait encore de
sauver une capacité quand il précise en
fait qu' ils voient bien qu'il y à une
attaque sur l'airé lever toute la partie
séparatiste mais qu'il ne pense pas que
la fédération de russie va l'attaquer
entièrement il ne pense pas qu'il y aura
une invasion de l'ukraine jusqu'à kiev
qu'on a comme on a pu en entendre dire
ces dernières heures
lui il limitera à la région à la région
séparatiste et c'est souvent en fait le
discours que vous entendez quand vous
discutez avec les ukrainiens alors c'est
forcément un peu différents selon qu'ils
soient pro russe où qu'ils soient pro
européens mais ils essayent quand même
toujours de travailler avec la personne
qui est à côté d'eux et c'est vrai que
ce qu'a bien compris le président céline
ski c'est que si la russie demain aller
jusqu à kiev il aurait beaucoup à perdre
parce que il n'y aurait pas forcément
une intervention immédiate des européens
pas forcément une intervention immédiate
des américains et qu' il serait donc du
coup soumis à un régime beaucoup plus
difficile et dans ces conditions il
préfère privilégier quand même cette
question en fait j'allais dire de l'est
de l'ukraine avec ces régimes
séparatistes et en même temps on voit
toute l'ambiguïté aussi c'est parce
qu'ils précisent que dans ces régimes
séparatiste il ne va pas aller discuter
avec les rebelles il dit moi je ne leur
parle plus or dans les accords de myst
tels qu'ils sont mis aujourd'hui sur la
table il faut que les ukrainiens de kiev
a discuté avec les ukrainiens du dombass
et l'ouganda et puis les autres sont à
côté les russes n'ont jamais voulu faire
partie directement de ces accords là
parce qu'ils disent nous on n'est pas
concernée puisqu'on n'a pas trop à
l'intérieur ce qui est faux on sait très
bien mais à la base quand il avait signé
il y avait cet accord il faut que les
ukrainiens se parlent entre eux et c'est
là-dessus en fait ce qui est en train de
se greffer vladimir poutine avec une
intelligence j'allais dire stratégiques
c'est-à-dire de se dire si je m'occupe
de ce petit territoire pour les
occidentaux il ya encore une fenêtre de
discussion on est encore dans le bras de
fer parce que je ne suis pas inquiet